Florida is also among the states where
the virus is far outpacing efforts to
contain it there have now been more than
3,500 kovat related deaths in that state
and more than a hundred and fifty-two
thousand total reported cases that is
almost three times the number of cases
just a month ago our lead national
correspondent David Beck know is outside
the Miami Beach Convention Center that's
a covent testing site David good morning
how is the state's a response here
evolving over time well take for example
the chief executive of the governor who
still refuses to require people
statewide to wear masks
he said yesterday hey listen we're not
going backwards I'm not closing things
again because I don't think open
businesses are to blame for the spike in
cases he did mention young people he
says he believes social interactions
among young people are partly to blame
and so he's asking them to be more
responsible but here in miami-dade
County which is the most populated
county in the state the mayor actually
did take a step back in fact yesterday
he said listen I'm going to order all
businesses that seat eight or more
people restaurants that scene eight or
more to close from midnight to 6 a.m.
because he said some of those
restaurants are turning into bars at
midnight and that's not acceptable
consider the numbers here in Florida on
June 1st the Florida Health Department
reported just under 27,000 new tests in
a single day only 2.8 percent came back
positive after the state processed more
than 43,000 new tests in one day more
than 14 percent came back positive look
we've seen images of backed up sites
across the state whether it's people
standing and socially distant lines or
sitting in bumper-to-bumper traffic at
drive-throughs we are Tony as you said
at the Miami Beach Convention Center
testing gets underway here at 9:00 a.m.
and I was just looking in the line it
looks to be I'd say 25 maybe 30 people
ready to go
Gail before I toss it back to you I
should tell you that the beach is here
for the 4th of July will be closed
starting July 3rd through July 7th no go
with the beaches this holiday weekend a
no go with the beaches ok David when you
look at the alternative something like
your life all you can do is give people
the information and hope they hear you
thank you very much